ouais ouais ouais en ce moment ma
nouvelle passion c'est de regarder les
gens streamés sur twitch parce que j'ai
aucune vie sociale en fait non
franchement je kiffe l'ambiance les
communautés sont cool
j'y passe beaucoup de temps c'est
peut-être pour ça que je fais très peu
de vidéo d'ailleurs alors qu'angers qui
savent pas tout il c'est un site super
connus où les gens c'est filmé en direct
en train de jouer aux jeux vidéo ou
faire ce qu'ils veulent d'ailleurs ça
s'appelle stream et le stream du stream
il stream oustry mon switch c'est le
site de streaming
je pense le plus connu ou tu retrouves
bas les puristes mais aussi youtube
guinea très cool également où tu
retrouves on va dire le grand public et
puis d'autres sites moins connus on y
retrouve bas personne alors il ya des
mégastars 1 / twitch pour ne pas le
citer ninja le médecin devenu la
mascotte de force knight et joue avec
drake trévise cote
il a fait le tour des plateaux télé
américain il fait des pointes à 667
millions ''vers plus plus de réussite
encore peut-être éventuellement poser le
pied sur mars je viens de poser le pied
sur mare aux [ __ ] ça excusez moi je
comprends pas le concept de regarder des
gens qui jouent un jeu franchement ça
ridicule
je préfère largement regarder des vrais
trucs à la télé comme le golf ou là ce
sont des gens qui jouent à un jeu
moi je trouve que c'est toujours
divertissant de regarder des gens jouer
surtout quand toi même à la base des
joueurs ou appuient les streamer pour
capter leurs audiences us ont souvent
très inventif taré mais inventif entre
le mec qui finit des jeux avec des
bananes
le mec qui lit entièrement le
dictionnaire et plein d'autres trucs
chelous tu t'emmerdes fort
a white witch ça fonctionne pas mal sur
le don donc si les gens apprécient ce
que tu fais ils peuvent te donner de
l'argent
du coup c'est vrai que ton niveau de vie
est entre autres rythmée par la
générosité des viewers quoi bonjour à
tous ça y est je me lance sur twitter ça
devient désormais mon métier
don d'un million de bons bajard et
twitch merci à tous expérience de six
secondes
je vais désormais vivre aux bahamas même
si chaque streamer et streamer sont très
différents tu remarques quand même
parfois quelques récurrence et je vais
pas me retenir pour pour vous les
évoquer c'est parti le pro gamer un
commentaire et gm
[ __ ] j'ai mal joué sous celui qui
débutent et qui est déjà à fond
ouiais ce biais du saumon là et j'espère
que vous allez bien vous êtes
actuellement en direct aux nombreux 2,00
à me suivre bon bah du coup c'est
certain que je parle on va celui qui vit
encore chez sa mère à six mois on se
plaît encore un peu celui qui veut
absolument trouver un nom à sa
communauté
bonjour mes petits chats ça c'est que
j'appris bonjour mais motoriste a lancé
nul bonjour mais musaraigne bonjour et
petit fougères j'espère que vous allez
bien celui qui veut absolument utiliser
tout le potentiel de son siècle de
gaming yes merci à timothée 26 pour le
seul j'ai du mal à parler quand je
contrôle très très peu pour personnages
en fait celui ou celle qui veut faire de
l'audience sans prendre trop la tête
bonjour mes p'tites fripouilles j'espère
que vous allez bien attendez je fais
juste un petit changement au niveau de
la cam
voilà là c'est beaucoup mieux alors le
streamer technicien michèle berthy 1 2 1
2 et quand je tapote comme ça vous
entendait aller au devant d'un petit peu
le débit de l'image c'était bien assez
fluide
celui qui partage toute sa vie privée
donc là ma femme est en train
d'accoucher cp normes
merci pour le solde à spa mail i-mode
bébé et demain j'enterre ma grand-mère à
18 heures soyez présent les poussières
épouse pourquoi les noirs
celui qui est très proche sa queue
alors ouais fred fred molotov c'est pour
te dire que le dîner est servi à mal
d'appétits peuvent plus aller au sahel
le streamer ultra sponsors pas à pabbi
belle bonjour à tous bienvenue sur mon
string que je vous le rappelle est
sponsorisé par leroy merlin
aujourd'hui on va jouer à battlefield un
jeu qui est disponible à la fnac chez
darty et chez boulanger à laon vois plus
mon visage mais sachez que je suis très
très content let's go le streamer un peu
maladroit allez bye bye mais petit
fougères je vous aime je vous kiffe le
vous adore ciao communauté de merde
yes j'ai pas déconnecter aller à demain
le streamer asmr et voilà on est très à
l'aise dans son petit canapé peut-être
que les bruits de bouche comme ceux ci
viennent doucement caressa l'oreille
surtout que j'aime manger du pâté amis
dit n'être que des petits coups de patte
et son coin c'est maintenant et oui il
ya le feu chez moi alors je tente
tranquillement l'extincteur comme ceci
je le caresse
alors les pompiers les actuellement le
feu je vais totalement celui qui se
tordent et petit challenge 1 comme par
exemple le stream et 48 heures non-stop
[Musique]
et bien moi bonjour à tous merci d'être
si nombreux à me regarder aujourd'hui
vous êtes près de 1000 c'est pas mal du
tout un sega vient de démarrer à la
baisse
il reste une personne merci à cette
personne on se bat non c'est moi en fait
il existe aussi la twitch conne c'est un
gros rassemblement twitch aux usa durant
cet événement et des compétitions de ea
sports 1 de jeux vidéo il ya des gens
qui sont capables de faire le tour de la
planète pour y participer il s'est
entraîné toute l'année
il a traversé toute la terre pour
participer à cette compétition
internationale
toute sa famille croit en lui
millions de viewers ont les yeux braqués
sur lui maintenant elle va jouer souhait
mais ce cas
merci à tous d'être venus je rentre
directement chez moi la france elle a
way on voit là et encore plein de trucs
à dire le sujet est vaste alors pour
info cette vidéo est pas du tout
sponsorisé un c'est juste un petit coup
de coeur car oui j'ai j'ai un coeur en
tout cas comme vous le savez moi je suis
100% youtube mais j'ai quand même une
petite chaîne switch donc s'il apprécie
les taupins les dizaines de frags de
qualité les actions incroyable de pgm
badiane et pas par contre parfois on
rigole bien donc venez me suivre c'est
twitch point tv slash norman stream le
lien est géographiquement présent dans
la description jusqu'à est faux alors
quel est votre streamer préféré ethicle
dans les commentaires c'est une fin mais
c'est mr je dis aux gens je te mettre un
petit pouce en l'air si vous avez aimé
et de vous abonner à ma chaîne aux non
abonnés vous à ma chaîne youtube c'est
indispensable pour la survie de la
planète
cliquez avec votre doigt ou votre souris
sur la [ __ ] de grosses têtes de jeudi
merci
[Musique]